[Music]
shout out standout tv
[Music]
plugged in
i started rapping during cover that was
bored still used to run up and down like
i'm wretch mill
i'm grown i need a couple houses and a
hundred mil i was in and out the t like
miller for the grands
never called four mans if i had an issue
i just dealt with that with two hands
used toting two shanks listen we just
threw hands tell me who the [ __ ] the
man the man make sure his family is my
daughter's fed
properly energies ain't stopping me
chasing the squawking property
demographically the system ain't been
trying to bust these human freezing rap
dead locked in hmp had three options rap
wanna hit the streets but all these kids
wanna be bad now
you trap wow think a rich car you've
seen five bags was five
stacks if you're dead or on a blue map
i'm trying to educate you out there
trying to deter me
i was dedicated way before i started
rapping you might love capping for the
net and gram
every minute snapping has location
settings hackers and
you see this while we living
everything's a [ __ ] image always
asking for assistance like my name is
kimmich
i got versatility but you ain't seen it
yet so i'mma give you all this pain
until there's nothing left
don't tell me stressing friends and
family on their last legs now i'm
running up these stairs until my last
breath
i showed love my situations left me
heartless all the elves in all the
hearts just made me tough
i've been drunk and trying to get it out
the mud i got a trapper in my veins and
in my blood
i don't wanna trap i don't wanna trap i
used to be
random fiends and them cats as a younger
this was normal
now i'm looking back i swear that [ __ ]
was awful you couldn't tell me about all
nights up in the d
i was raising random killers and then
fiends i was raising random
[Music]
kills
[Music]
[Applause]
of a certain night i was out doing wrong
man wanna know about life i do this
right and correct my wrongs
i did the perfect life there was certain
nights i was out doing wrong
i was trying to fill these pockets get
rid of poppers
man's been low to the point that my
pockets coughing girlfriend packs like
the emmy's copper dodging
out trying to get these readies get them
often little man hasn't ends too much
he's upper dropping
i ain't got time for the streets the
beef team's dead is way too long
man
[Music]
got hit with a 10 20 or maybe a 30 bro
little man got sent up soft
he chose this life he did it wrong that
he's paying the price credit check some
coke and whites and d
on nights man wanna know about life i do
this right and correct my wrongs
added a perfect life though certain
nights i was out doing wrong
that's some dirty deeds and i saw these
dirty fiends
i needed peas legit weren't paying
enough so i had to bang it up
i didn't want to bag the stocks see cut
these streets corrupt
might want to know about life i do this
right correct my wrongs out in the
perfect life though certain nights i was
out doing wrong
i had packs on a polo and i was moving
low low
jumping jumping like a pogba had packs
on a polo
and i was moving low low high patch
jumping
jumping like a pogo